. We have a voicemail number that is two one
nine two David P..
I got a voicemail from our friend, Dr. Eric.
Dr. Eric has two theories about Donald Trump's
Corona virus, both logical.
Let's take a listen to Dr. Eric Holland from
New Jersey, called a couple other times.
A lot of calls in the hospital.
A little bit.
You think about the idea that Trump actually
tested positive a while back and they were
hedging and planning on never even disclosing
it to the public, hoping they would luck out
and never have to.
And it was only after he started getting sick
that they said there's no way we can do this.
And they contradict.
He just tested positive.
And, oh, now we're bringing it to the hospital
preventively proactively.
Yeah.
I think that we're going to get to the part
two of Dr. Eriks voicemail.
That explains a lot of things.
It explains why doctors won't answer when
Trump had his last negative test, because
it probably wasn't the date, you know, Tuesday,
the day of the debate last week.
Trump showed up too late to be tested and
they went on the honor system.
The idea of being a we tested him when he
got on Air Force One and he tested negative
in all likelihood that he wasn't tested.
It's even possible that he had already tested
positive by that time.
That would explain it when we wonder why was
Trump given treatments that are usually only
given further into the course of the disease
like dexamethasone?
When Donald Trump got it on like day two of
his treatment, well, maybe it wasn't really
day two.
Maybe that was actually day six or day seven.
So what Dr. Eric suggests explains a lot of
the irregularities.
Let's continue.
I know that to me, I wouldn't put it past.
The thing is, he does not have a cage.
There is some nondescript corona virus illness.
He has Koven pneumonia.
He will catch candy.
Is that so?
So he's got pulmonary bilateral ground last
capacities.
He's got high inflammatory markers.
Otherwise, they would have said they were
normal to get a fever, low oxygen.
That's Cauvin Moldea.
And they they're really not disclosing it
that way.
Yeah.
So Dr. Eric, I believe, is completely right
here during the press briefings with Dr. Sean
Connelly, Connely doctor, the doctor for Donald
Trump.
He very vaguely said that Trump's scans and
done and X-rays, you know, whatever imaging
they did, that it all was in line with Trump's
health status and the progression of his disease.
And then when he was pressed to say, well,
does it show pneumonia?
Does it show irregularities?
The doctor didn't say.
And so, of course, Dr. Eric is right.
If they were able to honestly come out and
say every scan was the scan of a completely
healthy person, they would have done it because
they're desperate to make Trump look super,
super healthy.
I think that Dr. Eric is completely right
here.
It's speculative.
But you heard it from a doctor there.
And it coincides if you have an understanding
of propaganda, you would likely come to those
conclusions.
Dr. Eric has the benefit not only of being
a listener to this program so that he understands
the propaganda component as a doctor.
He also understands the medical component
and the implications of the symptoms and the
medications and the timeline and progression
of the disease.
Well said.
Dr. Eric, thank you for the insights.
Tonight is the vice presidential debate between
Kamala Harris and Mike Pence.
There was question as to whether it would
happen.
There was question as to whether there would
be Plexiglas separating the candidates.
The Harris team said, let's have plexiglass.
This is a highly infected White House.
Mike Pence was exposed that the Amy CONI Barrett.
Super spreader event and the PENSE team refused
and said, we don't want plexiglass.
If Carmelo wants to bring her own, she can
bring her own.
Well, as of this morning, everybody has agreed
to plexiglass.
It's very, very clear that what happened over
the weekend in the debate between Lindsey
Graham and Jamie Harrison, where Jamie Harrison
brought his own plexiglass and it just looked
bad.
It made it look like Lindsey Graham doesn't
care and isn't taking coronavirus seriously.
Clearly, the pense people realized, why are
we fighting this, we're going to do more harm
if we continue fighting the Plexiglas.
So we will have a with plexiglass debate tonight.
The debate starts at 9:00 p.m. Eastern.
But I have a suggestion.
Join me for the predebate show with your comments
and questions and a lot of different things
that will also be debuting a new a new song
that I think people will very much enjoy.
I will be live starting at eight thirty Eastern,
maybe even eight twenty Eastern on YouTube
and Twitch, YouTube and Twitch.
Join me there for the debate tonight.
Before that, we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today.
The United States Supreme Court is again reviving
criticism of gay marriage.
We will talk about the latest bombshell report
about child separations at the border.
And we will talk about how the Senate majority
being in the hands of Democrats or Republicans,
after all, is said and done on November 3rd.
The Senate majority may now hinge on a sexting
scandal in North Carolina.
Not everybody agrees it's a scandal, but some
people say that it is a scandal.
We will discuss all of those stories and much
more on today's bonus show.
Get access by becoming a member at join Pacman
dot com.
Otherwise, I will see you tonight for the
V.P. debate livestream.
Don't miss it.